what a beautiful spot
first things first i need to find a
place to sleep needs to be sandy flat
and dry
there's standing water down there
looks like more eyes
more frozen water
more ice there
i can see some gravel under that log
[Music]
this logs froze into the ground so gotta
free that
we've got a pretty stiff breeze coming
from this direction so just getting
underneath this log behind the snowbank
really makes a difference i'm a little
worried about my sleeping situation
though i need dry sand or gravel to
sleep on
i've got
clean gravel here
got clean gravel here
but i've got a giant frozen puddle right
here with probably three to five gallons
of water
frozen so i need to go and thaw out this
ground and dry it out
in order to be able to sleep on some
warm dry gravel melting ice takes a lot
of heat and energy it's going to take a
lot of fuel a lot of fire and a lot of
time to thaw this all out
got a bunch of these root balls here i
can chop up get a lot of good dead
firewood out of that
there's a lot of wood around here but
it's all frozen and covered in snow i
likely found a little stash of some dry
stuff
look at all this this is bone dry
driftwood that is going to help me out a
lot
got all this nice dry wood i want to
keep it dry
i'm not going to lay it down in the snow
[Music]
uh
all right got the fire going but now we
need to make it big real big
so i better get more wood
it's getting hot in there but i gotta
keep adding wood
[Music]
i've been chopping and hauling firewood
for three four hours now
i keep going
i am exhausted that is a lot of wood
i can feel the heat of the fire all the
way over here and that heat is getting
stored inside that big log and in the
gravel and in the surroundings
that is hot
i want to get in there and start fussing
with it but it's so hot it's hard to
stand near that thing i'm just going to
kind of let this fire die down a bit so
i can get in there
and then i'll start scraping the coals
around and we'll see what we got
underneath
uh
the gravel's coming along better than i
thought right over here is all thawed
and mostly dried so i'm gonna dig this
down really deep pile it all up right
here
make a nice little trench i'm gonna
build a fire over this frozen part to
thaw it out i'm gonna put some fire in
that trench as well
well we're making good progress but it
looks like i'm gonna have to get a lot
more wood
all right off we go
tell you what i'm tired i'm working
non-stop i haven't eaten
i've been doing nothing but cutting wood
and stoking this fire for hours
all right we'll let all this new
firewood dry once it's dry i'm going to
stack it up
well right now the fire's going where my
bed's gonna be so i'm gonna move the big
pieces of wood over to where the fire
pit's gonna be i'm gonna try to get a
fire going over there
then we're gonna take care of the bed
all right got a nice bed of coals some
really hot sand we're spread it out nice
and even
get my bed ready
i'm trying to bury the coals with the
dry sand so that it doesn't extinguish
the coals it just kind of smothers them
well just for fun i brought along one of
these laser thermometers and we're going
to take some readings of the ground and
see how well this sand and these coals
radiate heat on top of the coals right
now we're getting about 108 over here
we're getting like 115 and we're getting
like 130 right here
so it's about 100 degrees on top of the
coals but we have a few hot spots where
it's over 130 degrees
oh my it is toasty in here just getting
the heat from the fire and from the wood
and from the ground but i am hungry
i think i need to start cooking some
food i've got this bread dough that i
made up and it needs to rise just a
little bit so i'm gonna get it warm so
i'm just gonna lay it down on this warm
gravel i'm sitting on
i'm just gonna bury it just a little bit
and i got some honey and butter in this
little jar here
let that honey and butter melt right
there
a nice little steak we seasoned earlier
let's go ahead and put that
straight on the coals
the steaks just cooking away on the
coals let's check out our temperature
here
that 320 on the surface man that's
pretty close to what i would be cooking
at in a skillet that's pretty cool
for having cooked that just on the coals
that is a pretty beautiful medium look
at that
man that hits the spot
all right there we go
mix up that honey and that butter it's
all melty
there we go
oh
nice heavenly butter and honey just
dripping off it
oh
it's been a long long day it's about 10
30 at night right now and uh i need to
start thinking about getting ready for
bed here i'm gonna bust out my blanket
all right you want to use wool blankets
when you're sleeping next to the fire
because they're fire retardant you want
to be really careful when sleeping next
to fires before we get ready for bed
let's see what the temperature of the
ground is
got 74 degrees right there
54
72
so definitely a lot cooler definitely a
lot cooler but still
not too bad
well right now my feet are warm but
they're kind of wet because i've built
up a bit of a sweat so i got to pull off
my boots my socks and dry my feet off
and dry my socks before i go to bed so i
don't wake up with cold feet
gotta be really careful i don't melt my
boots
i'm just sitting here drying my socks
and shoes and i can hear the ice moving
on the frozen lake behind me
it's groaning and cracking and you can
hear ice sheets being pushed up on top
of one another
it's pretty cool actually look at all
that steam coming out of my boot that's
water that water will make you cold
well my sons tom nate and jake have been
coming with me on a lot of these
campouts i bet a lot of you guys are
wondering where they are tonight well
tom and nate had school so they couldn't
come
and jake
well
hey jacob
you want to go camping with me
[Music]
well jake's out having a good time with
his mom and that's that's important
one thing i gotta do tonight is i gotta
get all this firewood and organize it
and put it within arm's reach of my bed
so i can stoke the fire all night
a lot of this wood needs to get dried
out too so i gotta
do that as well
oh
oh it's nice to lay down my back's
killing me i'm gonna sit here and watch
a movie and kind of relax we'll just
kind of take it easy
it's a lovely night tonight well it's
been about five hours since i buried the
uh coals let's check the temperatures
got 89 degrees right there
76
and 59.
definitely still got heat
man you can still feel it
here's my pillow for tonight
ah
[Music]
i must have been tired because it's 5
a.m and i slept pretty good so i stoked
the fire up really good and that feels
really nice
my feet are really cold so i rolled some
logs down that way and built a fire
and hopefully that will warm my feet up
here a little bit
oh good morning
it's actually nine o'clock
well the ground's really hard but i'm
warm
the
fire by my feet keeping my feet warm i
feel some warmth in the ground still
not a ton but a little bit usually when
i sit on the ground it just sucks all
the heat out of you i mean even in the
summertime but uh not not now
it's pretty nice
oh my back
didn't melt my boots
always a concern
well i'm curious to see how warm the the
gravel is
46
i mean that's still pretty good
71. so we got about 60 degrees here
and we got about 22 degrees over here
so yeah big difference
i'll tell you what sleeping on 70 degree
gravel versus ice and water makes a huge
difference
smoked pork jowl bacon
all right we got our little set up here
let's start cooking
i need a better dinner plate
we're going to make one
look at that
just cook the face of it till it's nice
and crispy then you slice a little bit
off the edge eat it put it back on the
fire crisp up the next beef
look at that
i still got some honey butter left i'm
gonna make me another piece of flat
bread
yeah his dough is almost frozen gotta
let it warm up a little bit
there we go lovely piece of warm bread i
know exactly what i'm gonna do with this
[Music]
wow it's so good
smoked meat butter honey flour
these are all survival foods of the past
they're so delicious
i love them
oh that was good
i'll tell you what building a big
bonfire and burying my coals worked
great kept me warm and this was really
comfortable
but it reminds me that movie jeremiah
johnson robert redford plays this
mountain man and an old timer shows him
this trick and in the movie it looks
super easy they just dig a hole and
throw some coals in it and it's a fun
movie but it's it's not accurate if
you've got two feet of snow on the
ground you can't just dig a hole you've
got to thaw the ground out first
additionally you need the right type of
soil you've got to have something dry if
you throw wet mucky stuff on top of your
coals you'll just put them out
additionally if you go into the woods
over there you're going to have 12 to 18
inches of moss and organic matter on top
of the soil and you've got to burn all
the way through that stuff before you
can even get to the soil and it takes
hours to burn your campfire down to soil
when you build a campfire in there so
you really need coarse sand or pea
gravel or something like that so it has
to be like a frozen river bed or a
frozen beach or a sand pile or something
like that in order for this trick to
work well otherwise you're just gonna
use an enormous amount of fuel and time
and in survival situations
time is a scarce resource but i'll tell
you what if you have the opportunity and
the resources to do this
it works really well sleeping on 70
degree sand as opposed to 10 degree ice
makes all the difference in the world
well guys it's been fun i think it's
time to pack this party up
once again if you guys are gonna do this
make sure you use a real wool blanket if
you use a synthetic blanket it'll melt
when sparks land on it
ah she's been a good shelter but it's
time to go home
it's been a beautiful spot and a
wonderful trip i hope you guys have
enjoyed watching this video as much as
i've enjoyed filming it if you guys want
to see more amazing camping adventures
check out the camping adventure playlist
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
and don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos every saturday
morning i'll see you then
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
becca why do we have a dog